when you think about um m a you've said
multiple times like you shouldn't build
things you should buy them
why that is like so contradictory to i
think what most people are being fed in
terms of like go start a company go
angel invest in companies why buy not
build
yeah well you can i think you have to
think about it from two perspectives so
if you have you know i don't if you're
um if you're the creator of ethereum and
you have this idea and you're like this
thing needs to exist in the world and
like i shall be the creator of it that's
awesome you should go start that
business uh most people start businesses
for money they're tired of working at
their job they don't make enough money
they want freedom whatever the case may
be most of us work because we like
getting paid right and so what i like to
teach people is to divorce the two so
instead of building a business for cash
flow if what your goal is is to make
money then buy your profits don't go and
try to guess that the idea that you have
is going to eventually make you money
because that's often not the case which
is why you know we have more than 90
percent of startups fail and the average
entrepreneur has a salary of 60 000 a
year
even as the ceo of a business for more
than 10 years think about that for a
second why would i go and try to do that
when i could go on some of these
websites like biz by cell flippa
e-commerce flippers when i could look in
my little local laundromats in my area
and see this business right here makes a
hundred and eighty thousand dollars i'm
going to buy this business for 3x 180 k
using an sba loan and day one of me
owning the business i'm going to start
cash flowing 180k a year and then i can
take that cash flow and if i want to
create the next ethereum or whatever the
idea is i can do it from a place that
doesn't have to bankrupt my family and
these like war porn horror stories we
have of like i did it all for my garage
and my basement and then i lost it like
you don't have to do that and in fact
the average person just wants their
family and community to be better and
healthy and so they should probably buy
a business and not build something or
then build something from a place not of
fear and scarcity they can build it when
they have a little bit of a cushion
i've got my both my brothers here and
they've got questions for you as well
joe john what you guys got hey cody
thanks for doing this appreciate it hey
uh
my question would be really just around
getting started right i think we touched
on this a little bit earlier but i think
generally when people think about
diversifying their income streams when
it comes to passive income and looking
at different industries and businesses
they get a little scared that they're
not an expert at any one singular
industry right so how do you think uh
about starting to do that and getting
educated is it just partnering with
specific people in those industries like
you mentioned earlier or is there
another strategy that you think works
well
yeah well a couple things first i think
you should start from where you are so
like one of the first guys that i
started talking to about this and taught
how to do it is a guy by the name of
mark and mark was a digital marketer so
he basically did ppc he did you know
helps people
buy ads and stuff online
and mark would charge i don't know two
thousand five thousand dollars a month
to run these ad strategies for companies
but
a company's not gonna continue to
utilize mark unless the two to five
thousand dollars they that he that he's
charging them is turning into ten
fifteen twenty thousand dollars right
he's gotta make more for them than he
spends and so mark was making these
other people millions of dollars and
sure he would increase his fee but you
know he could only do it so much until
he wouldn't be competitive with the rest
and mark knew he was good so what i told
him is why don't you do an acquisition
through sweat equity and do something
called a profit share and equity
alignment for your work and so mark
ended up saying hey keep the two to five
k
instead of that i want 10 of the company
which equals the i don't know 50 dollars
you'd pay me over the course of the year
and i want ten percent of the profits
for the next three to five years and i
want twenty five percent of the profits
for everything that we're going to do
this year and so mark was able to
actually buy a business with zero
dollars down and using his sweat equity
and now he's a 25 owner of this business
that nets him a couple hundred thousand
dollars a year instead of his 50 000. so
that's step one if you have a skill that
does one of two things brings in revenue
to a business or helps decree decrease
costs for a business you can do a
revenue or profit share acquisition
that's step one all you do is change the
terms of your contract with them
the second would be if you're like an
accountant right um i think the easiest
place to start is you have a skill that
you already know accounting why don't
you go try to acquire an accounting firm
or because an accountant is a pretty
incredible skill skill for acquisitions
you could account you could have you
could uh buy just about any type of
business but i like to tell people start
where you are so like one of the first
businesses that i bought
was a plumbing company and the reason i
bought it is because i had a family
member that was a plumber for a long
time and ran a plumbing business so i
was like i'm gonna buy this i know the
finance side i couldn't unclog a toilet
if my life depended on it but like you
know about things like that so let's
partner together on this deal so find
another person who is complimentary in
your skill set i like that john
yeah thanks cody for doing this i really
appreciate it um i actually have two
questions so one of the first ones and
i'll just ask them both and then answer
them at your leisure is um
where do you go to find already
established businesses so you're talking
about the laundromats and stuff like
that um and then also why do you hate
franchises so much um
is it like the kickback what is it about
franchises that you don't like
yeah well let's start with franchises
because that was fun i love controversy
um
so uh i hate franchises one because i
hate being told what to do like that's
the whole reason that i
would start my own businesses and i got
out of finances i was an insufferable
employee like absolutely worst any time
you know anytime you get in a business
people are like
yeah this isn't the right way to do it
but we've done it this way forever so
let's just keep doing that right you
know and i was i was always inept at
being able to say yes um and so i hate
franchises because they have massive
rules so anytime you're part of a
franchise if it's a good one and
actually worth the 15 to 20 to 25 you
have to pay them they're going to have
all these rules and regulations and i'm
kind of like you know what i think i
know better and i don't want to listen
to your rules so that's reason one if
you're going for freedom which is what i
talk about a lot in owning a business
why would you give up some of that
freedom to somebody else to ultimately
be your other boss i don't like it um
second reason is i don't want to share
my profits why would i have to share 10
to 25 of my profits with somebody else
and you might say well because they're
going to teach you how to do the
business well if they're going to teach
me how to do the business that's a
one-time
endeavor i can learn all of that by
paying a consultant up front maybe i pay
them more or maybe i pay another
business owner more to give me all of
his sops his his processes um but i'm
not going to pay that business owner 25
to teach me that for the rest of my
ownership of the business no thank you
and then third is i like to protect my
downside
and with franchises they can mandate a
bunch of things for you like i have
friends that owns mcdonald's franchises
and mcdonald's will say okay we're
rebranding everything we need new
signage everywhere here are the new
rules and regulations with covid that
you're allowed to do or not allowed to
do it's going to cost you about a
hundred thousand dollars to five hundred
thousand dollars so go ahead and have
that implemented in the next 90 days i'm
not interested in that so that's why i
don't like franchises you can make a
bunch of money though so that is fair
um
i forgot your first question entirely
what was that again no worries where do
you go to find businesses so if you say
you're interested in laundromats where
would you go
do you scour the internet do you try to
network what do you do
so the best way to do it is offline if
you know like what what pomp is saying
is like well that's funny and i guess
you guys are all pomp that's a little
confusing i never thought about that
before um okay so um
the the best thing to do is not to go
native not to go digitally native why
because that's the easiest path right
anytime you have the path of least
resistance you have typically uh the
least return and so the best way to do
it is actually this so the the maybe
like the second or third business i
bought um was uh and i just own a part
of that business i own about 40 business
um that business was a service that was
provided to me it was in the media
sphere and i was paying this guy like a
pretty you know two thousand dollars
three thousand dollars or something like
that a month to provide this service to
me let's say that it was video
production and um
and this guy had a business that was
doing okay i could tell he kind of had a
job he he he had this business so that
he could have a lifestyle he was the
operator of the business he was in it
every single day and i was like hey um
you know let's call him tom tom do you
uh want to grow your business and he was
like yes stupid question of course i
want to grow my business and i was like
okay well i pay you two to three k a
month i think that i could get you
probably anywhere from 10 to 20 new
clients that were similar to me and we
could increase the prices and i think
some of your systems and operations
aren't that great and like you could do
these couple of things in your business
with 10x what if i invested money in
your business give me a look at your
books just tell me high level how much
profit you make in a year i'll give you
a reasonable return you know anywhere
from you know 1.5 to 3x um the
investment that i would make in it and i
want to own about 40 of your business
but i'm also going to help you grow the
business so we ended up doing a deal
where i only invested ten thousand
dollars in this business that was doing
about a hundred thousand dollars in
profit
but i ended up bringing them about
another hundred thousand dollars in new
client and now i own forty percent of a
business that does 350 400 000 something
like that of profit a year that is
totally doable so look at your look at
your checking account and your um credit
card where are you spending money
consistently over time and do you know
the owners of those businesses can you
talk to them about can you invest in
their business alongside them i think
that's one of the most underserved ways
to find businesses and then the next
thing that you want to do is like talk
to your dad's friends like talk to your
financial advisor talk to your attorney
talk to your accountant and look for the
gray-haired wave which are all the
retirees that are moving out of their
businesses that are tired of covered
lockdowns and you know this the move to
digital that don't want to do that
they've been running them for decades
and have face-to-face conversations in
your community then you can do it online
on some of the sites that i mentioned
before like biz by cell flippa
e-commerce flippers et cetera hey guys
thanks so much for watching that clip of
the best business show make sure you
like and subscribe to the channel turn
on notifications so you know when we go
live every weekday and then head to
sofi.com so that you can get an account
we can get after it